[BatPat]: February 18th, 2023, I finally
cracked it. These creatives with their comic
books making movies have zero respect for the
science of style. No matter how realistic they
want their movies to be, they don't consider the
realistic consequences of the actions of their
antics. And now I have proof. Proof that Batman
should be dead. And the reasoning is explosive.
Hello, Internet! Welcome to Film Theory, the show
that knows that theorists are not as superstitious
and cowardly lot. Do you want to know how I know
that Friends? Just look at the wide array of
content that we've covered over the years. We've
exposed Mario's truly psychopathic nature, played
Rocket League in real life with real cars. We've
predicted the future of superhero franchises and
analyzed how to survive every single horror movie
imaginable. We've cried while eating spicy foods,
and we've worked out the best ways to get the
most bang for your buck at buffets. And now,
today, my friends, we're ready for the next step
in our theorizing adventure. Today is a huge,
momentous day loyal theorists. Today we are
launching the first new theorist channel since
2020. The fourth little quadrant of our logo
is finally getting filled, completing that
little Simon Says ring of YouTube and bringing
us one step closer to theorist world domination.
Ladies and gentlemen, I introduce you to Style
Theory. Yep. We have ourselves a whole channel
that's dedicated to style, fashion, beauty
and hygiene right now. With five brand new
theories over there for you to go and
watch right now after you finish this
one. Now I know what you're thinking: style?
How are you going to theorize about style?
Exactly the same way that we theorize about
film games and food, because everything and
anything that you're passionate about are things
that you can theorize about. The same research,
science, history and lore analysis that we
use to discuss and decode analog horror,
superheroes and anime 100% apply to
the very real world of clothes, makeup,
hair and hygiene. Did you know that
your old makeup might be killing you?
Have you ever wondered about school uniforms and
whether they do anything good for the students?
You know, Hulk’s purple pants? What do
you think those might be made out of?
And speaking of fictional clothing, have
you ever wondered just how effective skimpy
armor from fantasy movies and video
games would actually be? And lastly,
since we're talking about movies,
what about Cinderella's Glass Slipper?
Can you make clothing out of glass? Or
like on the new Netflix show Wednesday,
she says she's allergic to color. Can
you actually be allergic to color in
your clothing? All of that and more
is going to be coming your way over
on this new channel. So go check it out
after you finish this episode. Right now,
subscribing to Style Theory is the single best
way that you can help both us and yourself out.
Not only are you going to be getting yourself
some super interesting educational videos about
all sorts of fun topics that are all very
real and applicable to your everyday life.
But if we can manage to get a million
subscribers by the end of the month,
that will put style theory as one of
the top fashion channels on YouTube.
So help us help yourself and let's dominate a
whole new portion of YouTube my friends. The link
to Style Theory and its five brand new theories
that just dropped today, you heard that right,
five new videos that are brand new
right now. All of that is in the top
line of the description and the i-card in
the top right hand corner of the screen.
So go click on that over there, but make sure
that you're opening it in a new window, because
here we’ve still got to talk about one of the most
iconic pieces of clothing in all of pop culture,
the Batsuit. Loyal theorists, there have been
a lot of Batsuits on film over the years. We've
had spandex suits, rubber masks, military grade
spelunking gear, comic accurate capes and cowls,
and even Bat-nipples for some reason.
But I think my favorite incarnation of the
suit so far has to be the realistic version that
we see in director Matt Reeves’ The Batman. See,
this suit looks like the stuff that this
Bruce Wayne could have realistically found
and cobbled together himself. And it really
followed the vibe that was set by the rest
of this version of The Caped Crusader.
The Batman follows the tried and tested
formula of Bat-films that we've seen over
the years. Bruce Wayne's parents are killed
in front of him, turning him into an edge-lord
cosplayer, who takes out his frustrations on
the superstitious, cowardly lot that is
the criminal underworld of Gotham City.
But this go-around, things are a lot
more grounded. While Christopher Nolan's
Batman was a suave globetrotter with
unlimited resources, and Zack Snyder's
Batman was a murderous psychopath with an
exoskeleton mech. On the surface level,
this Batman seems a lot more realistic. He
wears combat boots that he probably picked
up from the local army surplus store.
He drives a muscle car Batmobile that
he clearly modified himself. He listens to
Nirvana while journaling about his feelings.
The film even embraces the idea of cycles of
violence, with Batman being the inspiration for
a lot of the lunatics that he's trying to stop,
which sometimes gets just a wee bit too real.
Matt Reeves and the other filmmakers involved in
The Batman clearly put a lot of time, effort and
energy into making this the most practical,
realistic and down to earth iteration of the
character that we've ever seen on film. Which is
why it's so weird for me that the Batinson shrugs
off bullets with such alarming regularity. At one
point even takes a shotgun blast point blank to
the chest, before smooching Catwoman, dusting
himself off and beating the poop out of the
guy who shot him. Seriously. For as grounded as
this take on the hero might seem on the outside,
the Batman has bullets bouncing off
of the Batsuit more than Superman's
chest. And that just didn't sit right with me.
Are billionaires suddenly reality benders now?
Well, not exactly. You see, loyal theorists. Even
if Batman had the best body armor in the world,
his ability of affluence wouldn't have let
him limp away from the events of this movie,
and not for the reasons that you might
think. I don't even have to go into that
ridiculous scene where he face-plants into
a bridge going like 45 miles an hour either.
Nope. The reason that Batman would be dead is
a lot softer than that. So put on your super
suits and stand broodingly in the rain
there, loyal theorists. Let's dive in.
So let's just start off by looking at
how exactly bulletproof armor works. See,
bullets are deadly because they concentrate
an enormous amount of force onto a small
surface area, allowing bullets to tear
through almost anything that they hit.
Bulletproof armor works by taking the force
of that bullet and then spreading it out
over a larger surface area. Preventing it from
penetrating your body and wreaking havoc on your
internal organs. Don’t get me wrong, it's still
going to hurt, leaving you winded and bruised.
But it makes it substantially more likely
that you'll be able to survive getting shot.
We've actually touched on this subject before
in my Game Theory discussing whether or not
you should bring a knife to a gunfight. And
we found that bullet-proof isn't exactly the
right phrase. Bullet-resistant is more accurate.
In pop culture the most commonly cited type of
this sort of bullet resistant armor is known as
Kevlar, which actually isn't what you probably
expected to be when you hear the word armor.
The stuff isn't some sort of metal or anything
like that. It's actually a bunch of
synthetic fibers interwoven together,
which makes it really good at dispersing the
force of bullets as they strike the Kevlar. Yeah,
you heard that right. Kevlar is technically
a fabric. Fun fact, Kevlar was originally
developed by the DuPont Company who were also the
minds behind another superhero staple, spandex.
We actually talk about exactly that and a whole
lot more in our episode about Hulk's pants. The
new episode over on Style Theory. So you should go
check it out. Just another shameless plug. Anyway,
most of the guns that are used by Falcone's
goons and the Riddler's henchmen were either
pistols or submachine guns that fired nine
millimeter rounds, which Kevlar would do a
pretty good job at stopping.
Buuuut here's the thing,
that's talking about firing from a distance.
When fired at point blank range, like we see
quite a bit during The Batman, Kevlar doesn't do
the best job of stopping the bullets. Depending on
where they hit the armor, some bullets would have
a good chance at breaking through and entering
the body. And that's not even mentioning
that some of the bad guys use bigger guns
with more powerful bullets, especially during
the finale fight above Gotham Square Garden.
Here we can clearly see Batman getting hit with
bullets fired by M16 and Winchester rifles,
which both shoot 5.56 nato rounds. And remember,
Kevlar isn't bulletproof, just bullet resistant.
And 5.56 rounds fired by those rifles would
absolutely be able to break through it. No
problem. Thankfully for Batman, though, Kevlar
isn't the strongest type of body armor out there.
It's actually considered a soft body armor,
which you can clearly see here in this video
by Taofledermaus. Notice how it basically folds
around the bullets to stop them? It almost looks
like it's catching the bullets, right? Given
the fact that we don't see anything like this
happen when Batman gets shot in the film, instead
the bullets just bounce off of him with sparks.
Clearly, he's wearing some sort of hard body
armor. According to the National Institute of
Justice, there are five different categories of
body armor used in modern times. These include
Level IIA, Level II, Level IIIA, Level III,
and Level IV. Just in case you're wondering,
level I body armor does exist, but it's no
longer considered acceptable by the NIJ. Also,
those “A” classifications just get shoved
between existing classes when an armor
doesn't quite fit into one of the categories.
The IIA through IIA levels are all soft armors,
with Kevlar ranking somewhere right in the
middle there. It means the Kevlar is actually
on the weaker side of modern body armor believe
it or not. That might come as a surprise to you
if you've ever heard that Kevlar is stronger
than steel. And yeah, I mean, that's still true,
that just doesn't paint you a complete picture.
Kevlar is indeed up to five times stronger than
steel. If you compare their strength to weight
ratio, basically steel armor that weighs the
same as a Kevlar vest won't be offering that
much protection. But that doesn't mean that
steel can't stop bullets. If you're willing to
wear a full suit of armor out into the field.
The YouTube channel Demolition Ranch actually
did a test to show just how effective steel armor
can be at stopping bullets. But steel isn't even
the best option for plate armor nowadays. We are
long past the Middle Ages, after all, and Batman
has himself the entire R&D department of Wayne
Enterprises at his fingertips. These days, the
highest NIJ rated armor consists of several solid
plates, usually made from some sort of ceramic
composite, something that is literally harder
than the bullets that are being fired at it.
According to the NIJ, the strongest level for
armor is able to withstand armor piercing
rounds, quote, “obtained from U.S. military
M2 AP ammunition”. If none of that means anything
to you, which, why would it? We are talking about
some seriously heavy firepower. This stuff
can penetrate three quarter inches of steel
with no issue. Those ceramic plates are going
to be able to stop the weaker nine millimeter
and 5.56 ammo shot by most of Riddler's
and Falcone's goons no problem. Honestly,
these plates aren't even that expensive by
Batman standards. I was able to find commercially
available military grade nine and a half inch
by 12 and a half inch level four armor pleading
for just around $600 per plate. And given Bruce
Wayne's resources, it's even feasible that the
parts of the Batsuit that needed to be flexible
and aren't armor plated could be made from Kevlar.
So this super suit of armor might actually be
legit. It would also probably be able to stop
that point blank shotgun blast that briefly winded
Batman during the finale fight. YouTuber Paul
Harrell tested common shotgun pellet projectiles
against level IIIA soft body armor, which is
weaker than the ceramic plates. And things
went really well despite multiple direct hits.
Even when testing much heavier slug projectiles,
the heavily compromised level IIIA vest was able
to stop the bullet, even though a great deal
of concussive force was able to get through.
That force would have been lessened had this
been level IV armor like Batman's wearing,
probably saving his life even if he got knocked
to his butt, which perfectly lines up with what we
see in the movie. Batman gets hit by the shotgun,
and though the armor stops the projectile,
he flies backwards from the concussive force.
So is that it? The Batman's armor is legit?
Does all of this prove that Bruce Wayne could have
put on this Batsuit and had all those cool fight
scenes in dark hallways and come out on the other
end with only a few bruises to show for it all.
welllll, not exactly loyal theorists. Because
bullets bouncing off his armor isn't the only
life threatening situation that Bruce Wayne finds
himself in in The Batman. During one of the most
tense scenes in the film, The Riddler straps an
explosive collar onto the district attorney's
neck in an attempt to get him to confess who's
at the root of the government's corruption?
Batman, both trying to save the DA's life and get
himself the same information. Stand's real close
so he can do the whole gravelly whisper schtick
instead of just talking like a normal person.
Of course, because we're only about halfway
through the movie at this point and we can't
solve the mystery yet. The D.A. refuses to give
a name and the bomb goes off, throwing Batman
across the room and knocking him unconscious.
Yeah, Naah. This absolutely stretches the edge
of believability in a lot of ways. But the most
obvious one, given that we just deduced that the
Batsuit is level IV pleated armor, this scene and
the explosion would have 100% killed Batman. See,
explosive ordnance disposal suits, or just bomb
suits for short, are very complicated pieces of
clothing. Up until the mid 1990s, they were
actually made of Kevlar with armor plating,
all in an effort to stop shrapnel
from killing the bomb technicians.
But that type of armor didn't provide
protection against the blast waves. In
the unfortunate situation where an explosive
actually went off, they produced shockwaves
that ripped through the bodies of the people
that were trying to diffuse them. So even if
there was no injury from shrapnel, the lungs
and other internal organs of the person would
be wounded. Oftentimes these wounds were fatal.
This was actually such a huge deal at the time
and happened so frequently, that these sorts of
injuries earned themselves the nickname Blast
Lung. Researchers found that the Kevlar and armor
plating by themselves just couldn't offer enough
protection. But when they were layered with
both a high and low density acoustic foam,
suddenly the people in the suits were far
more likely to survive the blast wave.
So because of this, modern bomb suits are made not
only from Kevlar and ballistic plating like we see
with Batman’s suit, but also several layers
of both high and low density protective foam.
That's partially what gives the bomb suit that
iconic, bulky look, which the Batman lacks with
its thinner, sleeker silhouette. And all of this
is without even mentioning the bomb suit helmets,
which have themselves giant thick visors made
from fully laminated acrylic and polycarbonate
to protect from shrapnel entering the face.
In short, there's just no way that the Batsuit in
the movie has the protective layering required to
survive a point blank explosion, especially when
Batinson's lower face is completely uncovered.
In fact, now that I'm thinking about it,
even with the super strong, basically bulletproof
suit of armor, you would think that Bruce Wayne
would be smart enough to cover his entire face if
he’s expecting to be shot at all the time. Between
that and approaching an active armed
bomb without any sort of bomb suit? Yeah,
I'd say that this Bruce Wayne has himself an
active death wish. Forget The Batman. Robert
Pattinson is more accurately described as
The Deadman. But hey, that's just a theory,
A FILM THEORY! Aaaand you know what other
superhero hasn't self an unrealistic
costume that stretches the bounds of reality?
The Incredible Hulk and his purple pants. If
you want to know why exactly these things stay on
the Hulk while all his shirts rip off his body or
why this single pair of pants probably costs more
than a luxury Lamborghini, you should probably go
check out the brand new channel Style Theory. Link
is on screen right now! and that's not all loyal
theorists.In addition to that Hulk episode, there
are four other new episodes over there today. That
is five entirely new theories covering everything
from how your makeup might be poisoning you,
the conspiracy behind women's pockets, whether
math can make someone's face more beautiful,
and whether or not you can literally kill
someone with your clothes. Please go on over
there and subscribe to Style Theory so we can hit
a million subscribers by the end of the month.
It's absolutely free. Your help would be
wonderful and much appreciated to all of
us over here who've been working really hard
on this channel. And if we can manage to hit
a million subscribers by the end of the month,
oh, that would be amazing. Thank you so much
for supporting the Theorist efforts over the
years and thank you for letting us get to this
next major milestone in our journey. I love you
guys and I'll see you on this channel next week.